- a musical bromance sting and Shaggy we
love this so much and only our Brooke
Anderson was invited to the Miami set of
their new music video hey Brooke hey
guys can you tell I'm excited here I am
in Miami with the one and only sting the
one and only Shaggy and they're telling
me how they became the new buddy-cop -
OH
these two are given us
Miami Vice vibes there are Paris police
detectives cruising around the city in
the new video for their song got to get
back my baby
we love you children you like each other
well it's obvious yeah yeah you had fun
together
oh yeah and we're friends on stage in
Austin the song from the rock legend and
the reggae icon is from their album four
four eight seven six the title of the
album are your area code yeah magic
Great Britain's forceful sting and
Shaggy also tour together and gave me a
little preview you never know what you
got till the moment that you lose it I
gotta get back my baby stick him up
Sting's real name is Gordon Sumner and
he just turned 67 we first met him
nearly 40 years ago as the lead singer
of the police he previously been a
school teacher if everything else fails
don't sell any more records and no
phones welcome back to teaching so
what's his secret to that Fountain of
Youth
I have no secrets so I do yoga I swim
every day that's why I'm this one in his
life in in a sea in Miami and then
someone said you shouldn't do that
there's sharks out there yeah they were
so today has obviously been pretty
magical for me I hope you guys have had
a good day
back to you in Hollywood well you're in
Miami with sting and Shaggy so not as
good as usual even close Yeah right well
you can see the full video for gotta get
back my baby at et online.com
[Music]